let's start off by having a look at just
that just that no one will refresh our
memory right will do under this first
graph will do y equals x squared we
might even put a couple of graphs on
each one just so we don't have to draw
so many axes now you remember y equals x
squared it has this up funny shaped up
we gave it a name recorded a parabola
right so you should draw for yourself a
nice parabola here ok this is shape if
you need to excuse yourself don't just
do it and let the rest of us guess what
for whatever reason like I don't care
what the reason is like I really don't
give a ribs like just okay yes yeah yeah
I'm doing it you should be doing it so
this is our standard parabola now want
to remind you okay it's it's got this
curvature to it right and importantly
like right there if you zoomed in really
really close to the origin it should be
like almost flat across there okay it
doesn't it doesn't like balance off okay
it sort of gently comes down to what we
called remember I gave you two names for
that important point there where it
where it changes directions remember
what it was called two names the fancy
name the Latin name started with a V the
vertex are very good and vertex is just
Latin for a turning point right it's
turning around so this is our kind of
normal version y equals x squared right
this is the parabola let's compare it to
some different ones hmmm let's have a
look it's a question
1c do once it so this is what once he
asks us to draw y equals x squared minus
seven right so you can see it's so so
similar to what we're graphing before
right x squared x squared minus seven so
that minus seven the effect that it has
is it takes that entire shape and it
shifts it or moves it down seven units
right if I was at the origin before will
now be seven units below the origin if I
was at some point up here suppose that
was five I'll be five below I'll be
seven below that which would being named
to somebody that right so in fact you
can actually get your ruler and if this
looks accurate this is what we can do
okay I don't know what the scale of
yours looks like okay but suppose if we
went down on mine let's see I'm gonna go
that far on my diagram that's ten
service obviously you also be a bit
smaller biggity idea okay maybe it's
three centimeters for you so I'm going
to call that number there negative 7
okay so i'm going to be down there
that's where my new turning point would
be i can get the rest of the points by
going anywhere and going down the same
distance right so if i said that was 10
centimeters other 10 centimeters from
say yeah and 10 centimeters from here
right so all of these are going to be
shifted down so now if i try to join the
dots okay i'll bring you something like
this
okay you see same shape but it's just
been moved okay now this is not easy to
draw it's not easy for anyone really
it's not easy with white board marker
it's not easy in new books which is why
I actually highly recommend for this
whole topic any time you have to do
graphs with curvature to them like you
can't just use a ruler right uh you can
get a template like you just put it down
it's they're not cheap unfortunately but
you can get them for like twelve to
fifteen dollars if you go hunting and
try and get one special school sells
them but they're full price but but the
key is it's just like a and rulers are
bad it's just like a stencil I think
it's like 16 or 17 so you know how
there's stencils right and you know when
you're first learning how to do that is
characters so there's an outline of like
the letter A like this right and all you
have to do is pick up your pencil put
the stencil down and then you just trace
through you like and then you take off
your stencil and there's a perfect a
right well when you do this you've got a
parabola shape and there are other
shapes there which is useful as well
right and you'll get it perfectly like
the courage will be perfect every single
time and it won't take you a long time
and we precise so for me like you know
if you're doing in the maths later on my
stage six you're going to keep on
drawing these so I feel like it's a
worthwhile investment I got one when I
was in your nine and I kept on using all
the way through until year 12 okay I
would still be using it but I'm
fortunate there but fragile mine broke a
little bit but it was enough so there
you go now i want to point out something
interesting here okay see how you've got
a y-intercept ear it's negative 7
because it used to be 0 and then we went
down seven units is that okay ok now
there's a wideness it here but when we
moved it down now we've got x intercepts
as well see these two values over here
right so from a spot here and a spot
here how would you work out where those
are I'm not going to answer it just yet
I just wonder how would you go about
trying to find it what does it look like
roughly on your diagram how
you actually find it out exactly man um
wouldn't like contests wouldn't there be
like those little dots okay so so there
might be zoom in on the access so you
might get something like this right but
I'm going to tell you right now because
I know what the number is supposed to be
that that's not going to then on a dot
it's going to be between some dots right
now then you might think or is it a half
but how do you know like how precise how
accurate is your drawing I know mine is
not all that accurate you just get the
general shape ok so I'm going to let
that question sit in your mind for a
little bit we will answer eventually but
I want you to think how would you don't
you find out what these things are right
we've got we've we know what this is
that's easy okay but what about the
others keep thinking on let's move on to
another question let's have a look at
excuse me and we'll do too let's do to
be too big we'll do that on our next
graph over here ok so again you don't
have to do this every time but I like to
do it so you've got the comparison we
looked at this yesterday if i've got y
equals x squared i'm going to draw that
first it's for the first one yep what
about the dollar do you mean like where
are they like they include so far
anything so it says state the vertical
translation which we did it's negative 7
yes and the coordinates of the turning
point so the coordinates at that point
would be we can write that in now it
would be 0 negative 7 that's where the
tourney brilliance no not yet we will
get to it though it's not that hard but
it's a bit of a that's a problem we have
moved out yet ok so again having a look
at to be here's my y equals x squared
graphite I always sort of mentally start
with that and then I think about what
the one that they've given us how is
that difference so two bases this now I
wonder if you remember we had a look at
these
last time this was an uptown a vertical
shift because I'm changing the Y value
over there here I'm changing the x value
so instead of up down I'm going to be
going left right yeah side to side
that's right that's a little bit tricky
it's a minus two right that means I
actually go and you can drop this down
to the right two units if you ever get
confused about is to the left or is it
to the right because it is easy to
confuse them all you need to do is put
some noise in there you can draw
yourself up a table those and you can
test it out and then get the coordinates
okay but the point is that you don't
need to if you can remember this right
that's just a like a last resort so
let's draw this right if I go over a
couple of units like so so there's my
two units to the right ok so now this
turning point that used to be at the
origin it's going to be here now I i
like to think at this point because it's
the most important point in the whole
thing ok so now I draw it again do you
mean this point here yeah yeah yeah it
does if you think about it like this you
always said it increases right but it
never goes like actually straight up it
never goes completely vertical so
eventually it's going to hit the y axis
somewhere ok now then that leads to the
question well how do you find out what
that somewhere is how would you go about
doing that mmm it's a similar question
to how do you find out what these are
right ? ok all right let's see if we can
answer before move any further ok
because I want to look at some different
kinds of heat graphs over here um Kyle I
think you had a suggestion for how to
find these values how would you go about
doing it ok factorizing right what are
we going to factorize is the question
that I have ok now when you have a look
at this right it's actually interesting
this number doesn't factor I as nicely
sevens of prior
number so here's the way I'm going to do
it I get different color on these two
things right there where the graph
intersects with which axis which is the
it's the horizontal so it's the x-axis
and so we call these things x-intercepts
do you remember that y intercepts is
where you hit the y axis x intercept
aware you get the x axis so I've got one
over here and I've got another one over
here I've got two of them okay how do I
find them for the x axis right
everywhere along the x axis the y value
the up-down value is zero i'm not i'm
not up and i'm not down so to find these
i say let y equal 0 that's what i'm
going to do to find the x-intercepts
okay all right I'll you like that to
find X intercepts let y equal 0 so
here's our equation x squared minus 70
equals x squared minus 7 okay
suggestions this is an equation we solve
these before what do i do to it show me
the working as well don't just give me
the answer okay i'll add 7 to both sides
excellent good pink ok I've also swapped
it around because it's a bit normal to
have the protein one-on-one time so now
the only way to simplify this is to take
the square root of both sides like this
x equals the square root of seven but
hold on we have a problem right the
square root of seven get your calculator
out for a second because it'll tell you
what the square root 7 years I am
guessing it is between two and three
actually I know it's between two and
three what is it 2.64 ok now I say that
was new 72.6 for ok I'll just take that
as you know roughly right now I know
that I'm on this side of the axis how do
I know how I know this one's 2.64 and
not this one think about it
yeah very good good what is the viewer
exactly right this is going to the right
which is positive this is going to the
left which means it must be negative but
I don't have a negative answer down here
why don't I have a negative answer
because you didn't put a negative good
it's cuz i forgot um it's actually well
it's actually the last line of working
this one here i should say plus or minus
plus or minus right do you remember this
is going back way back to a moon doing
algebra a couple of terms ago when
you've got this this is called up
quadratic equation quadratic because it
has something squared you know like a
quadrangle I can square that anyway so
this is a quadratic wait it's got two
solutions to it that's a funny thing
about these these equations with a
square dinner in fact bit of a bonus for
you when you've got a three there how
many solutions would you expect three
hmm interesting and come back to that
idea later on that's a negative question
ok anyhow so therefore we got the first
one this is the square root of seven
over here to roughly 2.64 I should put
up you know approx and then the other
one over this side is just the same
thing but negative that's all minus 0.6
4 or negative roots am ok so let's see
if you were paying attention you to find
the x-intercepts I let y equal 0 that's
what i got in here-- to find the
x-intercepts let y equal 0 here I want
to find the y-intercept how would I do
that perfect well done so find the
y-intercept I let X equal 0 it's exactly
the other way around it's come up
looking from the other side so this is
the equation I've got in this question
it's a new question now right and
everywhere I see x i'm going to put 0 y
equals 0 minus 2 squared what 0-2
it'll be it'll be negative 2 when it all
right and then I have to square it so
it'll be four because there's a double
negative and they cancel out each other
you just get left with the positive
that's for which I think someone said
before good pick so therefore that now
you got there is four ok yeah of course
I'm looking rub that off so by the way
you keep noticing I always start with
this x squared and then I think or how
do i change it right which is one of
reasons why it's so important to label
your graph so you can tell them apart
question the second the y equals x minus
two square bracket I you just find the
winter so we're doing minus juice that's
that's exactly what we did his own RV
you don't have to go through them be
well you see I think I think there's a
visit yeah well that's the thing you
always do though yeah absolutely like I
and it's not just better understanding
suppose I get it wrong suppose I just I
say eight instead like because I like I
know what this number is if i have i've
got no working i've got no way of
knowing whether that's right or wrong
and how to check working it shows you
understand what's going on and it gives
you a way to check if you've got it
right this yeah yeah it's it's the same
idea just I've written it all right good
question